Brittany's with us in Los Angeles hi
Brittany welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve
how are you I'm doing okay I have a
question for you so I graduated
undergrad six years ago I have always
been someone that prioritizes saving and
since I graduated I've saved about
seventy six thousand dollars in my 401k
I saved twenty thousand dollars in cash
and I just started last RA right now and
we have about five thousand dollars and
for you well god
thank you but so I just within the past
couple of months here I've been
listening to you pretty consistently and
the one thing that I haven't prioritized
is actually paying off my student loans
so and listening to you and following
your baby steps I've I decided to go
ahead and take that twenty thousand
dollars or eighteen thousand dollars of
it and put it towards my student loans
so right now I have about eighteen
thousand dollars left in student loans
which I'm trying to aggressively attack
the one thing though is that oh and then
I also stopped I was putting in twelve
percent of my income into my 401k and I
cut that in half I'm just expressing the
one thing though is that I've started
talking to my friends about what I'm
doing and they are just they're like are
you crazy you're a single woman how
could you only have two thousand dollars
in savings why are you you know trying
to attract your student loans they're
only federal loans they're not private
I've even heard some of my friends say
that you know if worst comes to worst
you can move out of the country she can
not pay your debt or are your friends
multimillionaires No
gives a crap what they think about money
you're going to take financial advice
from broke people yeah I know I know
it's it's crazy just some of the things
that said like moving out of the country
Gators they're broke yeah that's like
saying that's like saying I'm overweight
and I'm gonna lose weight and I'm
actually doing it and all my overweight
friends are making fun of my plan that's
kind of dumb yeah yeah yeah I mean who
cares what they think why are you I
wouldn't even discuss it with them like
somebody's been married 16 times and
they're gonna help you with your
marriage problem right they got the
honeymoon down then you got the marriage
thing down you know I'm saying right so
you've got it you know in business I
don't go to someone who has failed at
their last three marketing plans and ask
them how to do a marketing plan I try to
find people who are successful at
marketing and emulate those things
that's called best practices in business
it's the same thing here so I mean I
don't really care what your broke
friends think about money they're stupid
okay so what you've got to decide is do
you have sufficient evidence that in
your spirit in your mind and and and
that that the system that we're laying
out makes sense and you're really going
to go do it and if you don't if you
don't have sufficient evidence then
don't do it
but you know you shouldn't that would be
unwise on your part I don't want you to
blindly follow some voice on the radio
that would be weird too you know but but
you know read through the Total Money
Makeover go to the Financial Peace
University class do something like that
and then sit there and use your own
critical thinking skills but don't let
peer pressure from broke people tell you
how to handle money okay that's not
logical at all I mean they mean well but
they're stupid it's not that they're you
know they just don't that their life
doesn't have any
fruit in it you know I mean do you have
a friend that's really really bad at
selecting the men that she dates you
wouldn't take that would you take their
advice on whether or not you're dating a
good guy no no there man meters broken
right and that's the same thing here
it's the same thing it's just not
logical so I think you're asking the
wrong questions of the wrong people are
the right questions of the wrong people
you're trying to get affirmation from a
group of people that are not going to
give you information because they don't
have the the the capacity to then one of
the knowledge to do it and therefore
their life proves that so far I'm not
it's not say they couldn't turn it
around after you do but don't take
financial advice from broke people it's
a bad plan so hold on I'm going to send
you a copy of the book the financial or
the Total Money Makeover and read
through that and then you decide I mean
we've helped millions of people get out
of debt and to my knowledge we've never
caused a bankruptcy never caused some
might be homeless so you know it's it's
so it's not crazy you know I'm not
telling you to cash out your 401k I'm
telling you stop and pudding including
the six percent you haven't stopped yet
stop putting any money in to savings of
any kind and let's clear this dadgum
debt up you bought into it a little ways
but you didn't buy into it all the way
and then let's go ahead and get it
finished and get on a really tight
budget beans and rice rice and beans and
if you're broke friends don't understand
just smile and nod just smile and not
but they're not gonna understand but
don't look for affirmation in the wrong
places it'll get you in trouble in any
area in your life hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]